[Music]
hello and welcome to
the last stream of the year at least for
me
um today i'm gonna be talking about the
magnus number
and we are gonna look into
who i beat who beat somebody else
who beat magnus
and
um we will see how um theoretically
uh i beat magnus
i never did but let me enjoy my moments
so um
full disclosure this is an eight uh this
is on this is fully eric rosen's idea
and he was the one who mentioned this um
website slash idea to me and um he was
like i'm not so sure like i really want
to do it i just don't know when and i
was like you know what i'm gonna do it
next week i'm not sure if he managed to
get it in his schedule
so if you um
if he has or if he has not thank you
and um
the other thing to well there are
there's still club is still going to be
streaming tomorrow so just don't think
this is the last time of the year
it's just my last time of the year at
least on youtube
all right uh we're taking a break from
sicilian so this is not a sicilian game
we kind of wrapped up night off last
week
and we're still going to look into
never-ending sicilians
uh
probably for the whole january so
bear with me um
but
again i did not beat magnus but i beat
somebody who beat somebody who bit
magnus so my magnus number is
three what's yours check out on the
website and feel free to leave a comment
or
chat it's below
and
what is the website oh um
yeah
magnusnumber.com
fair oh you just want to say it out loud
ah that makes more sense thank you i
should have played along ah man
all right well yes please feel free to
check on the website uh which was
likenessnumber.com let me increase the
cpu a little all right
and
without further ado
let's jump in it so first i'm going to
show the
guy that i beat well he was on i am back
then he is the gm now and i actually
wanted to check to see if he crossed
2600 not yet but very close i think he
was like 25 75 something like that so
hopefully he will cross 2600 so i can
add him to the list of 2600s
that i've managed to um get points from
all right so um this was a very
interesting tournament and
well switzerland and i was going to say
zurich and i was like wait that was not
a zurich it wasn't beetle open
um
2015 which is a very funny year 2015 was
when i was trying to actually switch
federations and i was
thinking about switzerland so i was
there a lot
and it's a whole different lifetime at
this point
okey-dokey so
jess right let's go
uh this was a very very interesting
game because i actually remember that i
prepared for this opponent and he was um
i've seen him in like other tournaments
around because i remember like we were
both in like the junior championship or
something and i remember seeing him so i
knew that
like i was familiar to a certain degree
and i when i was preparing for him he
was always an e4 player but with me i
was a lower rated i was like 200 or
something lower than him
actually not even 200 like 150 lower
than him and he really wanted to i guess
beat me
and he went for d4 which is weird like i
don't think you should be switching your
opening that drastically just fyi unless
you're super confident confident in it
all right i played my normal ideas i
went for
the uh my
beloved queen's indian
and
he played this d5 so i'm gonna take a
moment and just gonna see how the chat
feels
also
who was calling me a crazy lady from
downstairs i mean who's downstairs
oh that would be tracy
all right well we'll have a we'll have a
talk tracy all right
so what do you think
uh when can we get a video on the banana
bread defense
to be honest this is the first time i'm
hearing banana bread
in chess terms
is it just me or
yeah if the if there is an e4 b5 i'm
not gonna be doing it i would just say
eat the free pawns
but
all right like to move what to do and
please let me know if this is something
that you play because it's kind of
tricky you you do have to know what
you're doing
all right
um so nobody nobody's feeling like they
want to share in this
d5 what would they do
what is the idea behind queen indian
defense let's see
the first response that comes to mind is
i'm going to sit behind the board stare
deep into your eyes and wait for you to
blunder or run out of patience and i
will enjoy that and i will
swap in and
collect material and a lot of the points
it's a very very patient game the kings
in the undefense on the other hand or
the groomfeld is very
boom boom like we're gonna castle we're
gonna attack here so i think i hit the
mic
um sorry for your ears and i just like i
wanna be able to attack attack attack
what's the idea well once for queensland
and defense
i'm assuming that's still tracy because
ben is sitting right here if any
question would ask me um
their idea is that i'm going to just
develop i'm going to just get my pieces
out and wait for you to
make decisions i'm going to be a passive
participant in the game for a little bit
and when i join back i will let you know
the power of my fists
seriously i'm not kidding i have a lot
of games like that that i would just go
like c5 or like knight e4 and f5 and the
whole thing goes up
so
d5 you want to take it is it free pawn
at least momentarily
what is d4 knight f6 c3
called why why do i get these questions
all right we are actually taking it the
idea is knight h4
uh they're going to kind of bother me a
lot about this pawn
so i have to choose very carefully on
how to proceed because
it's a pin right here so i can't really
touch this pawn and i really need to
defend it otherwise they take they go e4
and
um
then that's that's not a very
comfortable position
so c6 logical take
take and
here they went tonight f
knight f5
so there i mean there's potential for
take but i do not recommend it because
then this bishop can become very
monstrous so i don't think take is a
great idea
uh knight five is a pretty good idea now
the ideas behind knight f5 is i want to
go e4 kick your knight and when you move
the knight then i want to go like knight
c3
and you still your pieces um as black
the pieces are just so
um
constricted so you have to be able to
break
through somehow right
um so
uh the main line is with first of all
let's just retreat the knight like i
accept my knight's position is kind of
crappy i don't want to stay out there i
don't want this e4s and everything and i
want to prepare for d5 and for some
reason in the game
i
was a little uncomfortable that this guy
just played d4 for the first time in
front of me and he knew so much of the
theory and he had something sharp
prepared and i just didn't want to walk
into whatever he had prepared so i chose
to make a move that is
not really great but it's also not
i mean it's development it's not great
but it doesn't also result in a
excruciating
future so i went for knight a6
and he went e4 i still move the horsey
he and then here he went to e5 let's
talk about e5 for a minute
what do you think about that
the other options instead of e5 could be
possibly like knight c3 maybe rookie one
something a little bit more chill
he went for e5 so i want to kind of get
some opinions
from the chat i see a lot of hmms and
haas
and i see it in facial expressions
in my in-person audience
i'm getting a
strong head shake
why not
fair but i'm also not attacking it just
yet
it stops d5 you might want to do knight
d6 as white
oh good question uh the somebody's
asking what is the question well the
question is what do you think about e5
if it's good idea then
make sure to calculate for black if it's
a bad idea then what else would you want
to do
also this is a very interesting um i've
been teaching a lot
over the past six months oh boy and i've
i just finished doing
the
camps
nine to four upstairs my poor brain
but the point is that um like with the
kids that are involved i see a lot of
likes
like reoccurring patterns of mistakes or
like things that they would miss
um the biggest thing that i see that
people make mistakes about is
they
automatically stop thinking after
certain points like they calculate like
two three moves and then they're like
okay so i take they take i take they
take oh i don't like that and they don't
push one move further so i was telling
them like i was making like a scary face
and like a funny voice and i was like
just whenever you're stop
thinking just imagine this scary voice
of mine that keeps telling you to push
one more move and just kind of
push it just see if there's anything out
there
especially in longer games like this was
a classical rated games so this wasn't
like if the bullets are rapid but it's a
rapid yeah you don't have that much time
to take your um sweet sweet time
but
this is a very common mistake that i see
people just don't push enough
and the other thing was like the concept
of loose pieces loose pistors or like
wobbly pieces are so uncomfortable
because they're a nice target as well as
you can simply
blunder them
in any time control so one of the
strategies that i do myself is
i don't let i don't like having
unprotected pieces
so e5 is a little uncomfortable because
it's unprotected and it's also a target
i understand the ideas that it holds but
like you can't go d5 because well i mean
blunder
but
you are also very
comfortable playing f6
it's the targets let's go attack it to
be fair knight c5 is also a potential
comfort zone but f6 is what i went for
all right yeah i mean jason you're right
the knights are connected in the edge of
the board it's kind of weird i agree
so f6 and
my opponent
i think she was
he
very
he was too comfortable he miscalculated
and mis-evaluated on all kind of misses
and you and bishop h6
now this is not a blunder but it's
very ambitious it's too ambitious if you
want something like an if you want some
sort of an attack you've got to start
with queen g4
g6 is probably a must a 96 is possible
too but let's say i do either of these
and then you still have to activate this
knight let's say knight out here then
you can maybe get bishop h6 and maybe
get knight d2 knight out then this is an
attack now you're getting your
sacrificed pawns worse
and i'm not so comfortable in this i
have to go like recap seven then they
can you know try to activate the knights
and i have two pawns up but they have
full compensation so this is very
uncomfortable for me
so queen g4 would be the best way to go
so he went for bishop h6
obviously i'm not going to take it
because i don't really like getting
checkmated
and i went for simple knight e6 now 96
is again not the best move because
there's so many different ways this game
can
continue
taking i felt like taking was too
ambitious like knight takes g7
and there are some uh interesting ideas
because i have a strong center
but
i just i don't have the heart for this
knight this close to my king i know
i mean there is like knight there's five
and the computer is surviving this but i
don't want to
if i have a choice between this or
something more comfortable like this up
to the top going knight e6
all right queen g4 and
um
what you kind of have to go to f7
and
then
he played bishop e3 which should be
three is a good move
and the idea behind bishop e3 is you
have to move it because i might want to
just go king straight i might want to
just take over here and i wasn't forced
into playing g6 either
so
they went bishop e3 i moved the king so
no more funny business
on this
file at least
and here again
very over ambitious f4 is too ambitious
it doesn't really you know you have to
develop you can't have an attack when
your pieces are just sitting there and
um i was thinking about a persian
expression but i can't translate it this
is the loose translation it doesn't work
sorry um
just sitting there and they're doing
nothing and they're just
doesn't it doesn't work like that you've
got to activate it knight d2 is fair
knight c3 is fine knight i3 even knight
a3 will do because you're gonna try to
activate the knight
there's a question about
oh kind of a few moves ago
okay let's take a small
back
and see what's the question about there
is a question about what if take take
take
and okay take fair
awards are you arguing d5 will live
black to center yeah i'm i'm happy with
this even if they take it that's totally
great i still have uh but ideas here
i'm not really worried about that even
if i don't want to do that jerky of
seven i'll kick your queen away i still
have a comfortable position
all right
i hope i answered that question
and we were here when they got too
ambitious all right now f4 is a pretty
pretty bad move
i wouldn't consider this a blunder but
it's definitely a
brown type of move
so what do we do
f4 is mistake but why
should we play
say that one more time
um should we play bishop c5 to enforce
the trade
um that's also a possibility but your
bishop is fine where it is because if
this bishop is not here knight d6 can
hurt
uh
yes
why yes
uh it's not impossible yep
we are hungry for their pieces hello
how are you doing
we just wanted to yeah
just keep in mind they're also live
streaming
they're also live streaming
yeah now this is a
serious threat that they can't really
stop
so opponent tried they went to as c3
and i continued
my
amazing
this
discovery on eating material
so even if they tried to save it i don't
think it would have worked that well
anyways because now i already have extra
pawn and this is also falling and this
is a problem and i don't really think
they could hold it that well
so yeah
and so he went to knight e4
and now what do you think is the best
move here
okay uh there's a funny question why not
tonight a3 well
uh for the same idea that i'm gonna do
in the main game here i would have done
even if you played knight a3
troy boy i mean the poor guy had lots of
hopes and dreams he was
following his own
chasing his own gm titles and norms and
um
yeah i'm fairly certain he's still sore
about it
no actually uh knight a3 here or knight
e4 here bishop a6 makes a lot of sense
just activate this guy
right
and after if they choose to move it well
and i mean i i don't even know what to
eat there's so many different
um continuations i can go for
so
yeah
all right so he went bishop d2 because
why not
and i ended up
eating more material than i ever could
have hoped for
and you still have to try to play it
precise but
the main goal is to uh simplify when you
have extra material
and my opponent's only hope is some sort
of an attack so let's take that hope
away
bishop g5 might not be the most precise
move bishop d3 seems to be the most
precise one or even taking but i really
just want to exchange stuff off i have
extra material i don't want to
feel so confined confined
and now
let's continue activating
all right
there is still dangers in this position
so you don't have the luxury of just
doing whatever you want
bishop h6 for example being one of them
you can't do something like that
because this bishop would get too strong
your king would get so weak you have to
you still have to find great moves so
try your best and find what do you think
is the best move for black here
you really want to to give them the
least
amount of activity humanly possible
taking the knight i think that's also
fine take take and then bring the bishop
back i think that's that's all right but
you have something pretty much
much better something more
more active
um
oh there we go my online audience
then personal audience you need more
time
sorry what no i'm listening
so
yeah the attack is going on we want to
try and
take
the attack apart g6 is the way to go
if they decide to take well great i'll
just take this if you take i will take
it again and then your attack is gone
so
um
knight d4
check
and
i just started to
eat stuff i probably should have played
bishop of five first and then when the
queen would move then i can easily take
that
and then just block it this would have
been the
more accurate way to go about it
but instead of bishop f5 to attack the
queen i went to h5 and then i took
and then i just went for this
simplification idea again
and um opponents could have still tried
to make my life a little more miserable
because this knight up here is still
pretty annoying
and i i can't try to go for f4 i can
still try to eat stuff there's still a
lot of ideas that i can do that will
give me a very comfortable position this
is already um like plus two like s minus
two
for black so um
i'm not really worried about how i would
continue but night takes just made my
life so much easier because i didn't
really have to
worry about this night being here and
and
not allowing me to free up my pieces
and my opponent continued for a few more
moves and i just
went for it
a little bit more
[Music]
and queen exchange voila
so the main idea that i had after i
managed to
gobble up some material was to
simplify the position neutralize the
attack simplify the position and it
granted me a win
so um
yeah the oh wait um
i remember that
so
i was playing noel studer i think
schtuder is the writer pronouncing it
and i beat him and then he so i had this
game in
2015 and then two years after this
he managed to beat ivan sarich
and even saric had beat magnus wait
um
well unfortunately before any of these
two games happened
but that's how you can kind of see your
magnus number so i beat studer studer
beat sorry sorry speed magnus so does
that mean i beat magnus probably in some
universe
somewhere
alter
alternate timeline something i mean the
matrix the matrix um movies coming up
soon or it's out already i don't know i
probably and i watched them last year
anyways so a different timeline anyways
but i am going to go over the studer uh
storage game more quickly because it's a
quite a long game and i still want to
show the other game that started beats
magnus 2.
so
let's keep going
let's i'm going to breeze through the
opening
if if this is an opening that you play
as white or as black or if you have any
type of questions in it
uh my first recommendation would be
double check
descent lewis chess club video library
if it's not there check some of your
other um
favorite streamers
uh
if it's not there leeches library
chess.com library chessable there's
so many chess
websites out there tyranny of choices
this confuses everybody
all right um so the position is getting
a little more interesting in this game
and if i'm not mistaken this was a team
championship that they were playing i
think it was in bundesliga so i'm sure
that they knew they were playing each
other a little while before they went to
the board and they had some sort of
preparation and um i feel like white
kind of got out of the opening a little
more comfortable than um
than black because this knight up here
it's not really doing much and it's
going to have to come back yeah it's
going just the next move is just going
to come back anyways and um it's weird
because a lot of the position
a lot of the ideas can just keep
bouncing back and forth like right now
white might want to consider doing that
right now black bone sticks they're
doing that so the pawn structure is a
copycat
well it's a not a copycat this mirror
copy there we go
and so it doesn't really um
it's not as exciting as the game that i
just showed you
but um yeah so like for example noah
went back and ivan uh legislature c8 and
they're just doing normal developments
and for the life of me i cannot figure
out why does he
like these knives to the corners
all right um
okay so a little more
uh a little more strategic oh there we
go some g5 okay i can live with that now
a little more um information about the
players so studer was
still not 2500 it's like 24
70 something and avon age is like 26 60.
so there is almost a 200 point
difference and um
200 points in that level is also quite a
lot and it's also with k10 like oh my
god you know how much games you have to
play k40 is so different k40 you win one
game you get like
40 rating points and it's just like
crazy oh my god i never had that i was
lucky enough
i had k20 that was also painful
anyways um
so this is different like black is
actually actively trying to create more
chances for himself
and so he's
he's playing a little bit more reckless
i would say
and that's that's part of chess um
usually one opponent is stronger usually
one opponent is higher rated they're
playing for something more and they tend
to be more aggressive even
psychologically because they
need that win or they
feel like they deserve that win because
there's you know that trading difference
so they do like
i'm assuming if black was lower rated
they wouldn't play this amazing like the
knight h5 and like
pawn push and everything
um
dm the k factor is published yeah i mean
for fitness yes
you so your feeder rating depending on
your age and depending on your rating
changes
if you are under 18 and if you're less
than 2 300 that's k 40
good luck
uh if you are between like 23 if you're
above 18
regardless of your um like even if
you're 1800 this k20 used to be k15 for
everybody i preferred that actually
and if you cross 2 400 regardless of the
age is k10
i know that there is going to be some
changes to the rating system very
briefly but i'm not so sure how and from
when
all right
so now that we've explained a little
about how the rating system works
um
i'm gonna take a breeder and ask you as
white what do you plan to do with this
guy
are you gonna castle
question mark
what about black or is black going to
castle
i see a lot of head
shakes i see somebody hiding their face
nice well um
uh dm i believe that the reason they
made the cave 44 under 18 was because
the kids have such a
they just
they don't like they can develop so much
faster and they can just play so much
better just for after a few months
and i don't i never felt comfortable
with it because it also felt like oh my
god talia if you look at talia's profile
she would get like so close to 2300 then
boom 21 something and then she would
again like gain that rating it's like a
it's a torture device
but yeah
all right so uh f5
i don't think anybody wants to castle so
but we still need to develop your rook
is fine where it is so i'm not too
worried about that
but you still have to be able to get
comfortable about your center because
opponent has more space
and your pieces are your pawns at least
are very
passive so f3 logical take take and e1
went knight e7 opening the rook and some
potential for knight to g6
maybe some e5 something
noah wentz
king of two and black started pushing i
like this push honestly uh it gives us
it gives black some future hope for h4s
too
knight g6 though knight g6
does not seem right
because remember like five maybe like 10
20 minutes ago on the previous game i
was talking about how a lot of my
students make mistakes with loose pieces
welp this is a loose piece
that ought to hurt
uh no uh
and this guy was like a 2660 grand
master as black in
loose pieces does not care about writing
all right so um now white managed to
get a little bit more out of the
position and he's playing very well as
well he's just activating his pieces one
after the other and c compare this
position to right before knights g6
black is so much more active in the
queen side and black is holding over
here
knight g6 kind of messed the whole thing
a little back and forth it is not not a
great choice
all right so let's go back to the
position that they were at right away
um
queen d8 take
and queen f6 all right now white has
pretty pretty dope advantage how do we
continue
the move here is
well a little crazy the best move but
there are other good moves as well so
i'm going to leave it up to you can you
try to find the best move
if not
still try to find other good moves
i have a question in chat about why
don't they reset rating two years
well let's see in the past two years i
have played very minimal rated games so
they would take away my rating that kind
of hurts i don't want that
i work so hard to you know get the
rating that i have so the same with the
title the rating and title day is their
lifetime they stay
oh i think i read this news recently
about fidel um
looking into doing
like titles and norms in hybrid events
so like if you're playing online in
specific tournaments
um
and specific requirements you might be
able to get a tie to get a norm towards
your title so
i think that's great news because the
past two years since they've been so
limited fida tournaments federated
tournaments it's hard to get a video
title so
good news
right any anything for white
troy boy i think you're tripping a
little
just a little
all right
i'm done talking about ratings i have no
other conversation about that
so
what do we do oh rook g1 i can live with
that
i agree
all right
uh rook g1 is a good move but it's not
the best move the best move is so weird
king e1
you're just gonna sing and walk away
with your king
you can whistle if you want to
but the point being you're just gonna
walk away with your king
and even if opponent tries to get
creative and you exchange it off and
then you just get candy too actually
first let's take that
then you can d2
and this position because of the extra
pawn that you have is way more pleasant
all right um this is like plus three at
least for white
all right all right
um rook g1 was played in the game and
black is still trying to hold i don't
fully come feel comfortable with king f1
just because of how this closes i would
just go king e1 honestly
but i'm not the one who played this and
white ended up winning the game anyways
so
not much
regrets although here there is a slight
regrettable chance
why to move
uh how do you feel about
the position of these two pieces
a little geometry huh
the coin is under attack
but
but
but
look if you know me enough you know i'm
not going to say no to pawns
and if take
boom this will fall too
yeah
and if they don't take they are going to
do what if they don't take what
queenish 4
can i just eat this now no this is too
winning for whites now
but white
at 24 70 missed the chance and he went
for queen f3
and then he just continued um he still
has a very clear advantage but queen d5
would have just made it so much easier
anyhoo i'm gonna try to go a little
faster on the end game because i still
want to show how black
in a different game managed to beat
magnus
you know that's kind of the cherry on
top to show how ivy like could have
beaten magnus in a different
life all right um
now this is a relatively comfortable end
game you just have to activate your
pieces yep there we go
and
then we are going to continue
activating yep maybe now king can come
well this is good turkey 6 is cool too
beautiful bishop e2 trying to create
some opportunities
nice let's eat a pawn or two
yeah bishop d3 um
helps the knight gets activated so
bishop f3 would be the way to go because
even if you take it then i'm going to
well
get a piece and if you move the rook
away then i can just defend this guy
so this would have been more comfortable
and no queen d5 is a fine tactic it
works
alright
so yeah uh bishop f3 was not played
bishop d3
king g5 was the way to go because now
they are going to continue trying to
activate the king and the knight
but
good for white and i guess for me
because if black didn't lose this game i
couldn't have said i beat magnus
so knight h5
king up
king up
and beautiful retreating
nice
nice
i guess that's fine too but
yeah i kind of have to never mind bishop
f3 doesn't really work
knight e4 and
peace activity
so when i talk about peace activity um
it's i'm not kidding like it doesn't
matter how much more material you have
if you can't use them i mean why do you
have them
some people make the same argument about
life objects you know like if you have a
pretty dish and you don't use it why do
you have it i think that's a slightly
different but interest if you if you
have it and you don't use it
well
uh yeah so king up
king in
i don't know why this was this happened
why not just take it and play bishop d7
maybe they were allergic to pawns in
this turn in this game
they just wouldn't eat
small tactical pawns
no this is fine
i think actually black could have hold
this still white is more comfortable
because of the piece activity but
anywho so knight d7 king in and
beautifully done
okay 136 and it's okay um
rookie 3 is fine as well and yeah one of
the big problems that black has is they
don't have enough um
ideas
yeah they can eat this pawn but what are
you going to do with your bishop
if bishop e8 well um that's going to be
a lot of fun for us
i'll eat that guy
this is falling this is joining yeah
this will be too painful so in the game
black went 98 to check king c5 is pretty
much the only move
bishop d7 and
nice
nice skewer shish keep up
and yeah this is this is just pleasant
i'm not um
i'm quite happy with how this game is
progressing
okay maybe we can eat one final pawn ah
no more pond it's okay
and four stroke exchange so this was how
um white managed to beat this game um
another strong grandmaster
euan sarich
lost
as black
and now
we are going to switch up
from this game
to
how elon starridge managed to beat
magnus
in less than 40 moves
so
ah there we go somebody checked their
magnus number it's number five great
yeah make sure to leave a comment or let
us know in the chat so what's your
magnus number
funny even started is the last link in
so many people's channels that's
that's fun because
i mean it's not every day that magnus
loses in a feeder rated classic game to
uh you know lower rate that's why when
everybody's lowered them but you get the
point
all right let's see how it's all
beautiful rui lopez ooh
yeah
um
i've tried this knight d4 as black
i never felt a strong connection to it
and if i'm not mistaken this was played
in olympia yeah it wasn't just olympia
so it was like a you know
big important events it wasn't just a
online tournament
so
all right we're going to go more
comprehensive i mean of course magnus
had a lot of preparation in what he
played
but
still
i feel like knight d4 kind of goes
against a lot of chess principles
all right um so
there are a lot of different ways a
black can play it they can take c5
d5s here magnus center d5 logical
take bishop b7 and
uh here t1 for bishop g4
castel seems to be more um
loved but bishop g4 understandable as
well
why don't people eat more pawns
i mean i get it there is c6 but
uh never mind it transpose we can play
h3 first and then it's okay i'm fine i'm
overreacting
they didn't eat the pawn just to move
later
all right and
i'm gonna actually take a small breeder
here
and ask you what to do as white
uh dm feel free to use the link provided
in the
description below
i also realized somebody named old uncle
bob
mentions
um
something in the chat about me using the
word any who
thank you thank you
ah there is i don't want to suck
anything i just want to keep my pawns
like i just want to move the queen away
queen c3 is all right too i just want to
move the queen away and i just want to
develop i want to play chill game i have
two extra pawns against magnus well i
don't but
white has
and all right so knight c3 and
yeah
rookie 8 was
was not really
not really what i am comfortable with
because f4 and then what do you do
you want to play b5 i'm going to block
that too
hallelujah
first thing that comes to mind is a5
they didn't play that he wins queen g3
that's fine too i'm having a little
trouble understanding black's ideas but
i guess that's why he lost so fast
but
uh
all right i'm gonna take another breeder
breather
sorry what's wrong with ricky that seems
kind of natural right now
or
earlier when you said
just gets to play f4 instead of rook e8
you ha like you have two less pawns so
you have to play way faster than shield
or k8 a6 b5 a6 yeah i can still do a4
but then maybe queen a5 so you pin this
you want to push this
white's only problem is that the bishop
is stuck so the rook isn't stuck
so if you give me some moves that i can
free up my position
i'll be very happy
so
yeah it's still why this is still more
comfortable but if black wanted to steer
something up that would be a tricky
eight is
too chill when your two pawns down
i don't have the hearts for it
but then again me sitting here
criticizing magnus doesn't really feel
that
amazing well you get some other things
exactly so i beat someone who beat
someone who beat magnus so there we go
i'm
practically i
you know it's same stuff
all right so
okay uh now we were we oh well we're
somewhere here oh 94
take take
b3 yeah that's fine i'm assuming d3 is
alright too but it gives rookie two so
just to not give that many chances
b3
queen move then okay now d3 let's bring
the rookie two and let me ask you why to
move what do we do
and while you guys are going to think
about it
you want to take away my reigning
ben simon
no you'll have a different rating but
it'll be taken away
little by little decay
we must improve to different rating
systems as time goes on okay i agree
with that just as we improved over the
old harkness system
there but do you remember how it was so
much fun like about 20 years ago maybe a
little more freda decided that women
were overrated so it took like 50 points
off every single woman chess player
i thought they gave every woman 100
points i know that they took a 50 points
they might have given 100 at some point
so it's i remember that story always
hurt me when i think about it they took
away 50 points of me i would
it's some of the questionable
administrative decisions over the years
don't yeah
yeah it's math
you can't change the math yeah they they
the rating system can definitely be
upgraded
i don't think that they care would deal
with inactivity that's
stop trying to take away my reading
but yes
that's fair i mean
i'm never gonna say no to developing
which also threatens to do checkmates
but
um
what else do you got
you can also just move the queen
somewhere else
your idea is you're just gonna get a
little bit closer so when you get closer
it's gonna be more painful
more impactful i think that's a better
choice award
okay so the idea is if you play bishop
g6 then bye-bye bishop
if you play g6 then i mean i technically
could still consider ah no no no no no
this is uh this is a different type of
bye bye to bishop i'm not too
comfortable with this queen a5
stuff can happen when your king is this
naked no king should ever be this naked
no there should be two let's just go for
the logicals
bishop e7
bishop of six
again logical
and
i mean this is like a desperate try
because if you take you lose the bishop
haha
but
intermediate moves
or in between moves
and now this makes a lot of sense
because
if you had to guess how much do you
think white is better white has two
extra pawns and amazing piece activity
well actually the third one is about to
fall okay now uh how much do you think
white is better
no no no don't look at the engine
like does it feel like a plus two plus
three or does it actually feel like
winning winning
yeah it's pretty winning
yeah
so like engine is giving it like plus
almost seven so
with the best move which is rookie 5 so
fun
all right um
yeah and then we get to push
which is again interesting because if
you take blunder will
so even if you have more material it
does not guarantee you win you need to
still find moves interested in
calculating to still um make sure your
opponent can't do whatever they
want plus your question mark
all right so d6 makes a lot of sense you
interfere with this this diagonals uh
creativity
and here uh magnus when drinking two
he's still trying to create something
but
it's too late the the wise position is
way too good
and it's not just the material it's the
actual piece activity
so here he tried to push for more
and um
white just chose a chill move such as
queen f4 and which is super winning
still bishop f7 is another way to try to
wrap it up but a bishop of seven after
king takes then we take over here this
is open this is opened
this is about to join oof
hurts my eyes
yeah so queen f4 simplification there is
it's a very logical approach to this
position too and after g5 we take
takitaki and beautiful want to pick up
another pawn
yes we do
what about this truth i think it's time
to join that that truck
i'm i really want this though
you know what i i understand let's go to
p7 so if any type of funny business we
get
rook d7
um
bishop takes d3
oh
wait could i just continue my funny
business
i guess i could but
why not just take this and have three
connected past pawns oh
beautiful bishop h5
might want to do different types of
checks at this point too oh spicy and
magnus here resigned
um
yeah so
um this was a very fun game for me to
watch because it's always
interesting to see uh you know world
champions losing
primarily because of the opening in this
case he's not like he blundered or
anything he just um
shows a weird opening that it didn't
play off for him and
this is one of those things that's why
you need to know your openings you need
to be super prepared for your openings
and at the same time it's very crucial
to
well as i said in the chapter in my
recent book
prepare
seriously like it's not not joke you
gotta prepare if you know who you're
playing you have to prepare if you don't
then that's
is there a better choice word for lazy
i wouldn't know anyways
uh so
please leave a comment below about your
magnus number
-3 let me know what's yours
uh so to sum it up i beat
noel studer hebitz ivan sturridge
he beat magnus so
does it mean i bid magnus
i'll leave that up for
the viewers that decide on their own
and
um
please stay around for
our switch to twitch segment we're going
to be analyzing your games
so bring a game leachate's format and
meet us there in about five to ten
minutes
uh
if you want
enjoy the rest of your year i will see
you in 2022
bye everybody
[Music]
you